Grant is finally on the plane on his way to the Expo. He's curious about how far
his plane is traveling though. He's not super familiar with the geography around
the city where the Expo is, it's called something like Udacity, maybe its called
Udacity. Hm, I don't know. However, he does know that Udacity is about 700 miles
north of some other city that he knows a bit more about, and that city's only
about 200 miles east of his town. To help him visualize the most efficient path
for the plane to take, Grant wants to draw a picture, but a picture that's a bit
more exact than the silly one I've drawn right here. If we say that Grant's
hometown is located at the origin on some coordinate plane, and we split our
coordinate plane up into chunks of square miles, what should the coordinates of
Udacity be, and the coordinates of the other city be?